[Music]
on this saturday night the return of
restrictions
the anxiety over the rise of omicron we
may have to consider something more
drastic or draconian the evolving rules
ahead of the holidays long lineups for
kova 19 tests we've been calling for
rapid tests to be deployed for over a
year now why critics say the government
mismanaged an important tool plus
boisterous boris britain's prime
minister is put on notice by his own
party and the court come back i just
looked at it and i'm like this may be
the last time i see you how a team
rallied behind a beloved coach
[Music]
global national with robin gill
good evening and thank you for joining
us all around the world and in canada
new restrictions are being imposed
because of soaring cases of kova 19
involving the more transmissible variant
omicron the world health organization
says omicron has now been detected in 89
countries it's spreading rapidly even in
places with high levels of immunity the
number of kova 19 cases involving the
variant is doubling every 1.5 to 3 days
in country where there's community
transmission canada is one of those
countries and there are projections that
omicron will soon overtake delta as the
dominant variant just a week to go until
christmas all the provinces and
territories are keeping an eye on
holiday festivities hoping they don't
turn into super spreaders david aiken
has our top story tonight
that shot scores
the montreal canadiens snapped a seven
seven-game losing streak on thursday and
no one was there to see it the hockey
club kept fans away after being asked to
do so by the quebec government to stem
the spread of covet 19.
it's a different game next door in
ontario where the toronto raptors for
example will still be able to play in
their arena monday in front of as many
as 9 000 people the hypocrisy of us
being told that we can only gather with
10 people in our homes but can go and
join thousands of other people in arenas
or hundreds in the community and
restaurants and bars
is unfortunate in the meantime business
owners are desperate for financial help
in the face of new restrictions that
come into effect at midnight saturday
right now the state of the nation of
small businesses very sad
only 35
are at normal revenues for this time of
year
the average cova debt 190 000 per small
business
18 and a half percent of ontario small
businesses are actively considering
bankruptcy
ontario is also struggling with its
rollout of rapid test kits a crucial
tool to help stem the spread of omicron
we've been calling for rapid tests to be
deployed for
over a year now so i'd say it's very
poor
it's it's very clear that rapid tests
are a useful tool it could have been
very useful for instance in reducing the
number of
outbreaks in our elementary schools
ontario used its provincial liquor store
chain the lcbo to distribute the tests
there were long lineups when the test
arrived friday morning but a day later
they're all gone also missing a system
to record the results of those rapid
tests data that is crucial for
responding to the spread i think
there'll be plenty of people who will
get positive test results who will not
want to then go out to get a pcr
confirmation
it'd be great to keep track of those
ontario's public health units meanwhile
are scrambling to get as many boosters
in arms as possible in kingston ontario
which now has the highest regional case
rate of coven 19 in canada officials
organized a drive through clinic to
speed up the process early morning start
great turnout a lot of people showed up
if there's one constant canadians can
expect this holiday period it's change
all governments were warning this week
as they announced new restrictions be
they for the border or here at a
shopping center is that public health
rules will change and change frequently
robin it's an involving situation david
aiken in ottawa
in quebec there is a worrisome rise in
hospitalizations and icu numbers that's
prompted the province to reintroduce a
series of measures aimed at slowing the
spread of omicron as elizabeth zogalas
explains more restrictions could be on
the horizon
with this pandemic we cannot rule out
anything speaking at thursday's press
conference quebec premier francois lago
says he had no choice but to once again
tighten restrictions as the omicron
variant quickly spreads across the
province the measures we announced today
are the measure we think that
will be enough to change the situation
but health experts say those rules must
be adhered to the situation could get
much worse we really need to follow
those measures to the letter and in fact
even do more than what the the
government recommends in terms of
protecting ourselves
for our collective good starting monday
stores bars restaurants theaters and
gyms will operate at 50 capacity private
gatherings will be limited to 10 people
the government recommendations are the
basic recommendations it is like the
bargain bin level of of of what you we
should be doing but we should be trying
to excel and many venues are legron
ballet one of the biggest ballet
companies in canada is cancelling its
weekend performances of the nutcracker
and remaining shows will be postponed
until further notice the montreal
canadiens game scheduled at the bell
center saturday night was also postponed
and morning practice called off
hopefully over the next two to three
weeks that we can get that curve to
to come down a bit montrealers are
getting the message i had some tentative
plans for new year's eve and i had two
parties work parties i work in a
hospital everything's been canceled i'm
definitely meeting less friends maybe
one or two but definitely not a big
gathering on saturday the premier posted
a message on facebook thanking all
quebecers for their patience he
reassured eligibility for third doses
would be expanded to all adults as soon
as possible elizabeth ogalas global news
montreal
british columbia is bringing in new
restrictions as it struggles to deal
with soaring covey 19 cases and rising
omicron concerns the new rules are
slated to kick in monday but as matagahi
explains several major sporting events
scheduled for this weekend have been
canceled because of covid
the puck was set to drop in just four
hours time when the decision was made to
cancel not one but two vancouver canucks
games at rogers arena this weekend as
more players entered coven 19 protocol
we're disappointed but
safety comes first the safety of the
players safety of the fans and
and i think this is the right decision
off the ice it's the same story for days
covet 19 testing lineups in vancouver
have sometimes stretched two hours while
many are scrambling to adjust to new
restrictions on social events and
gatherings in bc just days before the
holidays and ahead of what will likely
be a surging omicron variant wave of
covet 19. i recognize that this
unrelenting uncertainty and this
evolving situation is very unsettling
for many people and it can cause a lot
of anxiety
depression and discouragement friday
provincial health officer dr bonnie
henry acknowledged the hardships people
had faced in the recent months but said
the new variant had left them with
little choice vancouver island
it is moving quickly and so much sweet
hey how are you
indoor personal gatherings like holiday
get-togethers are limited to hosts plus
a maximum of 10 people or another
household while all must be vaccinated
sports tournaments are canceled venues
with capacities over 1 000 are reduced
to 50 percent and a uniquely targeted
restrictions suspending organized new
year's eve parties and events unless
they are seated without dancing or
mingling it's a complete surprise
that we've gone from planning for 100
capacity back to 50 capacity puts us in
a
unique position where we're moving
forward because it's too late to to back
out the restrictions are in place as of
monday with the province expecting
omicron to surpass delta as the dominant
strain of kovitt not long after
emmatagahi global news vancouver
the rise of omicron across canada and
around the world has prompted the
federal government to change the travel
rules again starting on tuesday all
travelers returning to canada regardless
of the length of the trip will be
required to take a pre-arrival pcr test
for more on the new rules and why
they're being brought in now let's go to
our ottawa bureau chief mercedes
stephenson mercedes
robin so many canadians have waited
patiently following the rules getting
vaccinated and masking up they were
excited to travel to see family around
the globe this christmas or take a sunny
vacation somewhere warm
now that's all on ice as ottawa is yet
again advising against leaving the
country in the face of the rapidly
spreading omicron variant
with health officials saying the most
significant omicron threat in canada
right now is community transmission the
government has faced criticisms from
some sectors for cracking down on
international travel so i asked
transport minister omar al-gabra to
explain the science behind his
government's decision the science behind
it is that which makes a lot of sense is
the less people have opportunity
to interact with other people the less
risk they put themselves
in and if they are abroad if they are
internationally uh god forbid they
contract uh uh uh covet uh we're at a at
a disadvantage as a government or uh as
a public health
system to offer services to canadian
citizens but also there might be at risk
of of being stuck in that country
starting tuesday all people arriving in
canada will have to produce a negative
pcr test regardless of how long they've
been out of the country that means
anyone planning a quick trip to the
united states will no longer enjoy a pcr
test exemption for getaways that are
less than 72 hours agabra cautions
anyone who may travel because of the
rapidly evolving situation with the new
variant that means you could see a lump
of coal in your travel plans that leave
you stranded abroad if you choose to
leave canada but also to protect them
against any sudden changes of uh root
border measures either in canada or
around the world
where we don't want to see any canadian
get stuck or are having to deal with any
symptoms abroad you can watch the full
interview tomorrow on the west walk
robin mercedes stephenson in ottawa
thanks mercedes the u.s is also seeing a
surge in cova-19 infections delta
remains the dominant and most deadly
variant in the country but at least 41
states are reporting omicron cases
experts say millions of americans could
soon be infected with the highly
transmissible variant jennifer johnson
reports
from state to state americans are
waiting in long lines to get tested for
covet 19 as the centers for disease
control predicts as many as 1.3 million
new cases of the virus by christmas it's
unimaginable to have to go through
another winter where you are overwhelmed
and
you have so much death and misery around
you new york on friday recorded its
highest single day number of new
infections more than 21 thousand
due to the recent spike there will be no
live audience for the taping of saturday
night live and the show will have
limited cast and crew a week before
christmas the rockettes have canceled
the rest of this season's shows schools
are closing pro sports teams across
leagues are postponing games it's covid
deja vu with expectations more than 100
million americans will travel between
now and new year's it makes me nervous
but i'm boosted and
my son's very good at wearing a mask
more than 800 thousand americans have
already died of cobot 19 the cdc is
predicting as many as 15 thousand new
deaths in the next three weeks the
unvaccinated over ninety million are
driving up those numbers for the
unvaccinated you're looking at a winter
of severe illness and death
for yourselves your families
and the hospitals you may soon overwhelm
despite the staggering numbers of deaths
americans remain divided over vaccines
and mask wearing a lot of people don't
really seem to care about the neighbor
as much as themselves doctors believe
the vaccine and boosters will give the
best protection against the new omicron
variant preventing the majority of
hospitalizations and deaths but there is
still too much unknown about that strain
it appears to be
about twice as transmissible as the
delta variant there's some suggestions
that it causes less severe disease
however the information that we're
getting on that has been in young
relatively healthy populations
this latest surge comes as new studies
show one in five u.s health care workers
have quit their jobs since the pandemic
began we're tired the hospitals are
stretched
resilience is low
the doctors and nurses who were left are
bracing for a winter wave that could be
just as bad as last year's they're
begging people once again to get
vaccinated and get their booster shots
jennifer johnson global news washington
the uk is reporting more than 90
thousand new cases today and london's
mayor has declared a major incident in
an effort to help hospitals cope calling
a major incident allows more
coordination between different public
agencies in the capitol london is
reporting nearly 26 000 new infections
today and omicron accounts for over 80
percent of these new cases hospital
emissions are going up so are staff
absences
it's really important londoners
understand how serious things are the
best thing londoners can do is to get
both vaccines and the booster they
provide extra layers of protection the
really bad news is those in hospital the
vast vast majority are unvaccinated
47 of people over the age of 12 in the
uk have received a booster
people in the netherlands are rushing to
finish holiday shopping before a strict
nationwide lockdown starts tomorrow only
essential businesses will be open all
events have been canceled and gatherings
are limited to two people from different
households and four on holidays so far
it's the strongest reaction to omicron
in europe and will last until at least
mid-january
coming up is it bye-bye boris the bad
news facing britain's prime minister
british prime minister boris johnson has
managed to avoid political damage until
recently this week his conservative
party lost a seat it held for two
centuries and then the cabinet secretary
had to recuse himself from leading an
inquiry into christmas parties at
downing street during lockdown it turns
out one of those parties was held in his
own office as redmond shannon explains
all these headaches have bojo's own
party turning on him
a by-election calamity for the british
conservatives
[Applause]
boris johnson's ruling party defeated in
a riding that has voted tori for two
centuries
i
totally understand people's frustrations
i i hear
what the voters are saying in north
shropshire and
in all humility i've got to
accept
that that verdict amid scandals
infighting and poor poll numbers the
once teflon-like leader is now in
trouble for a start the by-election was
avoidable the local tory mp had been
found guilty of breaking lobbying rules
johnson tried to stop him being
suspended but after a backlash the prime
minister you turned and the mp had to
quit i've
accepted that it was a mistake that it
was my mistake then came his response to
a wave of allegations that tory's staff
held christmas parties last year while
indoor mixing was banned i can tell you
that the guidelines were followed at all
times only for this video leak to emerge
from downing street this is recorded
its fictional party was a business
meeting
and it was not socially distant plus a
photo of johnson himself allegedly
hosting a trivia night the nose to the
left
126. add to that a quarter of his own
mps rebelling against tighter pandemic
rules and it's time for some british
baseball metaphors
first of all the conservative party in
the house of commons
earlier this week
now this result
one more strike and i think he's out
strong words from his own ranks for a
leader whose carefree style may be
wearing thin from being a kind of you
know
bumbling
um you know rules don't apply kind of
person that everybody sort of laughed
along with
it's now become yeah this guy doesn't
follow the rules he's become the issue
political watchers think tory mps
believe they need new leadership before
the next election more than two years
away i wouldn't be surprised if there's
a leadership challenge in the summer
johnson has defied odds before but could
now be facing his toughest battle yet
redmond shannon global news london
still ahead hundreds of thousands of
people are forced from their homes after
a powerful typhoon hits the philippines
the coast guard is still trying to
rescue people trapped on roofs and in
trees in parts of the philippines which
was battered by a deadly typhoon
thursday at least 31 people have been
killed since typhoon rai made landfall
the strongest storm to hit that country
this year the storm is set to move
through the western islands over the
weekend
at least 15 people are dead after a gas
explosion under a bank in pakistan's
largest city the blast happened in
karachi local police say something
ignited gas accumulating in the sewer
beneath the building but what caused the
spark is still unclear more than a dozen
other people were injured in the
explosion
up next the power of teamwork when
players get behind their coach
when shelton guy a high school
basketball coach in british columbia
lost his vision he decided to bench
himself he was struggling emotionally
with his new reality but his players
wouldn't let him quit and as jay durant
reports the power of teamwork helped to
make a comeback on the court
stay back reverse reverse with his son
jaden by his side and his players there
for support sheldon guy is still doing
what he loves
just three weeks after his vision
quickly started to disappear leading to
a heart-wrenching moment with his son
and i just looked at it and i'm like
this may be the last time i see you
and so that was at the stairs
so sorry
anterior ischemic optic neuropathy has
now claimed sight in his left eye six
years after a different ailment took the
vision from his right three steps
sheldon was able to adapt the first time
but this was a darkness he had never
experienced before i was in the hospital
and
i just
thought about popping pills and going to
sleep and never waking up again
but then the messages came from family
and friends and as players from langley
secondary one of the girls said
the only reason i joined basketball was
because of you
she said something like i don't even
like basketball
tell them izzy
who's that sarah morrison hey how are
you doing come here now early into their
new season they're finding ways to do
this together
ladies
long time friends in the basketball
community are just learning about what
has happened to sheldon the fact that
he shows up
and has just happened to him and i don't
even know all the details but i know the
guy that he is and hey ladies if you
have the ball ball fake see where the
defense goes
take it sheldon guy says basketball has
saved his life and now for a second time
he'll find a way to prevail he can see
some outlines but doctors say it'll
never be the same let's start pulling
and start taking some shots okay
guy isn't about to give up natural pass
say there was a chance he may be able to
reclaim a percentage of his vision and
that's the hope he'll always hold on to
i will see you again 100
we can do this conversation in your
office i'll walk in there myself
i will see you so i will see you again
thank you oops sorry sorry good job
ladies jay durant global news
what a great story and that is global
national for this saturday night i'm
robin gill tonight your canada is a
snowy evening in cochrane alberta we
would love to see your corner so please
keep sending your photos to viewers at
thank you for watching and i'll see you
back here tomorrow have a great night
[Music]